みなさん夏と言えば何を食べますか i えええ
では夏と言えばアイスを食べると思うんですけども何個まで食べた事ありますか
僕自慢じゃないんですけども中学校の時実家に住んでいまして大きな冷蔵庫買ってそれ
を6人で使ってたんですけども冷凍庫の中にはもう入っているものはほぼ決まっていて
冷凍食品かアイスカーアイスカー s しかなかったんですよねどちらかず結構みんな
アイスが好きで結構アイスが
なくなる頻度が多いんですよねでも気を抜いた瞬間異性が食べれないっていうことが所
つあって中学になった僕はどうすればアイスを食べるんじゃないかと思った時の越前つ
一個って制約を見せして暑さなんかばあちゃんのアイスを買ってきた瞬間に家族に6個
入りとかなんでその6個を全部食べればいいんじゃないかという結論に至って愛する
ことからねぇどこに設置された瞬間それをすぐとって自分でロ
を全部食って大年を食べられなくてするという満足感を得たんですけどめちゃくちゃ
怒られました何で僕亜実を食べる量が結構すごいんですよあのひとつの謎がありまして
僕が中学校の頃から大量のやつを食べる中お腹をこうしたことがなくて
よく言うじゃないですかアイス食べるとお腹今スってそんなことなになって僕を持っ
てるしボソ皆さんもう中こういうさほどアイス食べたこと
ないと思うんですよ僕検証です何個アイスを食べるとお腹が壊れるかを調べていこうと
思います一般的な成人男性のあたりなのでこれと皆さんに当てはまるとは限らないん
ですけども参考にまでしていただけると助かりますみんなお腹コース必要がないんで
その分僕がこうしておきましょう
今回食べているのはこちらスーパー
カップまあいろんなバニラアイスがあるんですけどもこれが僕の中じゃサンダーと
ナンバーにライスだと思っておりますカロリーが簡略初10kcal
結構ある杭そんなにあるんだろまあでまさにも書いてる通りバニラが王道なので今度
このオーソドックスな鍵ライスを使って何個食べると僕がをんだと壊れるかを検証して
いきましょう
いただきます
何万する好きだからそうとも好物を大量にくるっていう至極の時間はジョエルこと自体
最高ですがいただけますけど
[音楽]
ねぇ w
この結果によっては皆さんが何個までアイス食べていいかっていう間だが若かったです
から
アイスたくさん食べた人は是非参考になる動画だった
ずっと終わりました犯せば駅てー何でで食べてる感じがないのでまだまだいきますって
いうかと切るんじゃない
煮込みいきます
うんうんうわっ
ありました箱が遠いんですけど味が単調すぎてたくさん食べるですか
きてきましたでもまだ入るんでもうちょっと頑張っています
う
パワーオブコントもいきますいただきます
[音楽]
なんでだろう対象の1曲だけは本当にばいいんだよなどんな状況でもおいしいと思う
だろう
まだ何か壊れるきますねんじゃ打つべくハート頭がしたが低温やけどみたいになってき
たっ
あっはっ
いやあうれしそうなこっちゃダメだけどちょっと2台かもしれないぞをちょっと今お腹
に違和感を感じたとして頭痛いぞ
大豆クリーム頭痛的な奴がきてる
google ダメージパンッ
3つ見たました現時点で食べたカロリーは10140kcal でございます4つに
行きます
ええええええ
すごいすごいなら鳥肌立ってきたぞとりながら取り方がすごい生瀬寒いな
もうついても全然ねまだ意見客するんですよね
うんここ目じゃいます
徒花鳩原がいたっ
[音楽]
7日ハムが2世がに入った
あとめちゃめちゃ辞めちゃ
[音楽]
[拍手]
カロリー的によりは1900キロ春類は食べてますよ6本いきましょう
まあ中会えからこれ
[音楽]
ねえええ
ん口でいた美味しいんですけど冷たいものを食べ継手靴が痛いならコメです
もうかプレイ的には2000キロカロリーを超えてきましたねじゃんだろパンいただき
ます
ぱぱぱぱーん
はいはい誰
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
ああああああ
金井だはいだ羽田
払いだよ終わったやったーってバッハと頭と口の中と舌と鼻が痛いですね言って結果的
にアイスはまあ6個ぐらいへスーパーカップというの6つまで皆さん食べますのでぱね
すくリボ1んですけども食べ過ぎないようにしましょう
じゃあだろ
[音楽]